- Thank you all for
joining us on this webinar.
For those who don't know me,
my name is Florian Carle.
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institutes,
and I'm the host of this
series of non-technical talks,
co-sponsored by The Franke Program
in the Science and the Humanities.
The idea of this series
was to talk about science,
not in a scary way,
but by mixing other
topics like humanities,
art, design, music,
and try to really engage on these topics
that are seen as difficult,
but that we can really make
accessible to everybody.
So this is the 15th part in this series,
and we are delighted to
have Klem Jankiewicz,
who is a designer and uses
her practice to design
interface without no-code
for quantum computers.
So it's very exciting to
have her this morning,
or this afternoon currently in Israel.
So Klem Jankiewicz design
and builds this interface
but before this, she was
working with museum, theater
and other educational
institution to create exhibition
and interactive installation,
including one on the facade of the POLIN,
one of the most famous museum in Poland.
And recently she has moved a little bit
on the field of quantum physics,
working in collaboration with
physicists and engineers.
She has worked with
the Centre of Quantum
Technology in Singapore,
Xanadu in Canada, Pasqal in France,
and currently with Classiq
Technology in Israel.
And so the idea for her was
to build all this interface
and of course she will talk
about this in a few minutes,
but she has developed
among other some game and
educational experience
like Quantum Flytrap, Pulser Studio,
and Virtual Quantum Lab.
And so we have a lot to talk about today,
and so we are very excited
to have you at YQI virtually,
but hopefully at some point on site.
Thank you so much for joining us.
- Hi, thank you for having me, Florian.
It's, I'm really happy
to be here virtually.
And yeah, and
I'll talk today about
mostly the project I did
in the quantum industry
and how I look at it and
what's important for me there.
My name is Klem and I'm a designer
and for the last few years,
as Florian just mentioned,
I've been working with
the quantum industry,
mainly building visual
graphical user interfaces
to interact with the quantum technologies.
And this is what I'll
be talking about today,
and I'll start a bit about
user interfaces in general
and how I see this and
what's important for me,
and why I think building
those visual interfaces brings value.
And then I'll show you a
few examples of my works,
so one will be Pulser
Studio we built for Pasqal.
I'll show you Quantum Flytrap lab,
an interactive optical table
which is an educational tool
and also show you a sneak
peek of something that we are
working on with Classiq
which is not yet released,
so it'll be only show a
bit of it, only the design,
but hopefully it'll be
available quite soon.
And also I'll show one
non-quantum project,
but also it's something that I think adds
to this
conversation about user interfaces.
Yeah, so user interface,
what is a user interface?
A space where interaction between
humans and machines occur.
So it's a way we interact
with the technology, right?
So a language, different interfaces are,
we can think about it
as different languages
have to interact and
participate in the technology.
And you know, of course there are
many, many different interfaces
starting with what you see on your screen,
that's like the most obvious one.
But also, of course,
like a mouse or keyboard,
there are voice interfaces,
there are interfaces based on code
or more visual ones
like the ones I'm designing
and building.
And we need all those
different kinds of interfaces
because they answer to
different types of users.
They, and different use
cases, different situations.
So for example, fully visual interfaced
probably could be a bit problematic
when the vision is impaired.
So, anything from blindness
to looking at your phone in the full sun
when you can't really see anything, right?
So like different types of users,
but also just different
situation, different use case.
And so those different
types of interfaces, then,
they answer to those different needs
and essentially
by choosing what type
of interface we build
for a specific technology
and how we design this
interface is a choice,
is a decision of who can
participate in the technology.
And this is something that
is very important for me,
especially if we want any,
it's not only quantum,
any technology to be inclusive.
I think it's something
to really think about.
And when we do talk
about quantum computing,
the most popular types of
interfaces are very text-based.
This is, so it's usually either code,
usually some kind of Python library
or of course the scientific texts,
and you know, these are great interfaces,
maybe scientific text aren't
a typical kind of interface.
But in this situation, it's,
I do see it as a kind of interface
because this is,
it is a way to understand the technology
or to participate in the technology.
So these are of course great, right?
So this particular example is from Pasqal
because in a few slides I'll show
an example of a project,
of a different interface we did for them.
So these are, you know,
really, really great,
but they're not for everyone.
So one obvious example would be
if I don't know Python,
I cannot really use a Python interface.
And the same with scientific texts,
they require quite a
substantial scientific knowledge
to understand them.
And when we talk about quantum computing,
a technology that, you know, can
potentially really at certain point
can impact everyone's life,
can change a number of industries,
then I think there are a
number of different use cases
and user groups that
these specific interfaces
don't necessarily, aren't
necessarily enough.
And one example will be a public debate
that will be important
or is already important
and we should have ways and tools
for a more general public
to be able to participate
in this technology.
Of course education,
this is I think quite obvious
we should lower the entry point.
We should make it much easier
for people to enter this domain,
but also all sorts of business situation.
And this is something that comes,
that I hear a lot with,
while working with the quantum industry,
that, you know, this is a
very, very complex technology
and sometimes there are certain situations
where maybe those non-physicists
or people who are working
with those technologies,
they do, they would require
some more intuitive way
to participate or understand or interact
with the technology.
But I also think there are many ways
that it can be valuable for research
and even for the most advanced users.
And I will also talk about it
with the specific examples
of the interfaces I did.
Yeah, so I think it's
really, really important
to try to think of the different ways
that we can produce different interfaces,
different tools we can build
for people to access this technology
and to interact with this technology.
And the specific type of interfaces
that I build are the visual interfaces,
the graphical user interfaces
or the no-code or low-code interfaces.
And this is what I'll show you now,
a few examples of
projects I have worked on.
So the first example I'll show is a
interface we built for Pasqal.
So Pasqal is a startup from Paris.
It was co-founded by Alain Aspect,
the Nobel Prize winner from 2022.
And we built for them this.
It's like a visual and
interactive representation
of their technology
and it's a no-code development platform
for neutral atom quantum computing.
And I'll go back to this slide
I just showed
a minute ago.
And,
so these are the main ways
to interact with their technology,
to understand the technology.
So, they have Pulser, a Python library,
and of course a lot of amazing research,
a lot of scientific papers.
And again, these are great
but they were looking for
another way to showcase
their technology and another way to,
they were looking to build another way
for the users to be able to interact
with their technology.
And this is when
we built the Pulser studio,
this no-code development platform,
online platform for Pasqal.
And I see those three types of,
those three interfaces as
just like different languages
we can use to interact
with the same technology,
three different representation
of the same technology.
And they're all very useful
just in very different use cases
and for different users
for different situations.
Okay, so this is Pulser studio.
It's a beta version,
so it's available online.
Anyone can enter it
at pulserstudio.pasqal.cloud.
And it's a visual representation
of their technology,
an interactive representation
of their technology.
So the idea here was to go very low level
because it was, they
really wanted it to be
very specific for their
particular technology
and their research.
So,
yeah, and this is the interface.
So what happens here?
First of all, we have the register,
the, an arrangement of atoms,
and then when we arrange
our atoms in certain way,
we can, we build sequences
of laser pulses that are,
that we send to specific,
to all of the atoms or specific atoms.
And it's all very, very interactive.
It
can move everything around,
we can generate different patterns.
We want it to be very, very intuitive
and something that without any knowledge
on building the algorithms,
people can use as well.
We have the code panel here,
here as well also to show what's happening
and yeah, and these are
the light pulses.
We can easily change
everything, add pulses.
And there's also a simulation.
So if,
oh, it's, but if it's a
smaller number of atoms,
there is a simulation,
online simulation available.
And we can see step by step
what is happening here,
which laser
is being active when,
so it's, yeah, it's all
very, very interactive
and intuitive and at the same style,
and we have different features here.
And at the same time we can
see what happens in the code.
We can also, by highlighting
certain elements,
we can see how they are
described in Pulser.
Most important idea we had in mind
when designing this interface was
to make it really, really intuitive
because the technology is very complex.
And then we wanted the
interface to not to add
any complexity to this interaction,
to leave all the complexity
to the actual technology.
And we, what I really wanted it to work
in a way that even if I
don't know how to design
a quantum algorithm that makes sense,
like what you now see on the screen.
Obviously this doesn't make sense
from the quantum perspective,
but you can still use the,
you can still use the interface,
you can still easily play with it.
You can still arrange the atoms,
you can still make those
channels with laser pulses.
We really, really wanted it
to be super, super intuitive.
And when Pasqal published a beta version,
there was someone who wrote a review
and have a screenshot here
because I really liked
the way he described it.
And he wrote that,
"Pulser Studio is a fun
for the whole family."
And the way I understood it is
that it's something that can
be used by the professionals,
by quantum algorithm designer,
but at the same time it's
something that this person can
give to their kid and the kid can play
and just make, I don't know,
a smiley out of the atoms
and just, you know, play
around with the light pulses
and arrange them in different way.
And
it's still playful and fun.
And for me it really captures the idea
what we really wanted
to do with this project.
And one way of working,
one thing we did in the process
of designing the interface
to make it very intuitive was
to think about what is familiar for,
what would be familiar for the users?
And of course if we're talking about
visual graphical interfaces for
neutral atom quantum computing,
there is no, there are no other tools.
So it's not like, oh yeah,
there are those 20 other tools
and now we can only think about
how to make it better there.
We didn't have a roadmap here,
so we are looking at other solutions
from different industries
and different areas.
And for example,
for the channels with laser pulses,
we looked at all sorts of software
for editing music and making music.
So, mostly editing music or editing sound.
And of course the use case is
very, very different, right?
Because you know, here
it's we're editing sound
and here we're designing
a quantum algorithm.
But in the end of the day,
these are some channels
with a certain timeline
and with those waveforms that
the users can move around,
can change, can edit.
So we, to make it intuitive,
we tried to learn as much as possible
from those different kind of softwares,
but that are so well researched
and there are so many examples
what works best there.
And so this was one of
the things we tried to do
in this project and also the simulation.
So with those, the smaller setups,
it's an automatic
simulation up to six atoms,
and it's possible also to
simulate setups up to 12 atoms.
And there was,
when we were user testing the solution,
one of the physicists,
one of the develop,
the people who develop
Pasqal's technology,
so one of the people who
know about it the most,
this person told us that,
"I don't even have to think
what happens physics-wise,
I can just follow what's on the screen."
And I really liked it because
it was quite obvious for us,
this is, that this will be
good for the business cases,
it'll be great for education.
But then I was really happy
that it was also valuable
for their own internal research team,
so the people that know
the most in the world
about Pasqal technology.
And I know that they still use it
and that
a lot of the physicists and
engineers in the Pasqal's team,
they still use it.
And
this is also like a
very, very small example
of a very basic example
of how it can be useful
in this R and D, like
for an R and D use case.
So, a research use case
or development use case.
And
you can see on the left side the register,
the six atoms, six qubits,
and on the left side you see the code.
And when we highlight the atoms,
we can see where they
actually are in the code.
And when you look at it,
it's quite obvious that, you know,
to arrange the atoms in this way,
it's very intuitive,
it's very simple to do it
in this very graphical, visual way,
but to do it in code, it's
just not the right tool.
It sounds,
it's something that's quite obvious.
And of course there
are many different ways
the researchers use it,
but the, I think this specific one shows
in this minimum like very small example of
how it is useful for the researchers.
And of course, you
know, from the beginning
when we are developing this solution,
this business case was
very important for us.
So the, all the business
situations and this,
it just so much more efficient,
so much, it's much easier
to showcase the technology
when, the business people on Pasqal side,
but also the client side
when they have something
that is interactive,
that is visual, that
doesn't require, you know,
two months of studying
of how to use something.
And so this was from the beginning
very, very important point for us,
how to show,
how to make this interface
that it's very intuitive,
it shows the technology instantly,
but at the time it's a real thing.
For now, if you go to the website,
it's still not connected to Pasqal's QPUs,
but the moment they
release the QPUs to public,
it'll be connected.
So anyone will be able
to execute an algorithm
built in Pulser Studio
on their actual quantum hardware.
And now I'll show you another project.
And so this is the Quantum
Flytrap virtual lab.
It's an interactive,
also available online,
interactive optical table.
So kind of a sandbox where
users can drag and drop
elements and make experiments
or recreate experiments.
And this project started
at CQT in Singapore
over four years ago.
And we went there,
were a group of people,
work with physicists
and software engineers
and we worked
on a game or a computer
game about quantum physics.
And later we continued the project
and it became the Quantum Flytrap projects
and we decided to go
more into the direction
of an educational tool rather than a game.
It's free to use for anyone.
And I know that a lot of
educators around the world are
using it from high school,
high school teachers,
there's number of online courses
that use the tool during the courses,
but also for, at universities.
For example, the Oxford University,
they're using it at the
quantum information course.
Yeah so it's,
this one is mainly educational.
This was always the main idea here.
And I'll show now the platform itself.
So we have this board,
this is this virtual optical table
where we can
drag and drop elements
and just start like here
and we can edit all of the elements
to create whatever
experiment we'd like to see.
And
there is, we have up to,
we have a simulation.
So it's
the same simulation we used
for the project for Pasqal,
for Pulser Studio,
so it's not only, you know,
a playful, colorful visualization
but it's also like all the math is there
so users can see what
happens step by step.
And we have different
features that users can use
to learn more about what's
happening on the screen.
And we have up to four entangled photons
and we have a number of
saved experiments for,
because again, this is
an educational tool,
so this is, people can look at
different, famous experiments
and see how to recreate them in our lab.
Go back to the presentation now.
And the idea and the inspiration
is quite obvious here,
of course, it's a visual,
it's an interactive online representation
and simulation of optical table.
And of course we looked a lot about,
on how these experiments are represented
in the scientific literature.
So this is of course very,
in a way very similar.
We just made it interactive
and maybe also a bit more playful.
And the project, as I
said at the beginning,
the project started as a game
and later evolved into this
more educational experience.
And at certain point we are thinking
about changing the interface,
this graphical layer to
something a bit more serious.
But we talked with the
users and we found out
that actually
majority of people like
the fact that it was
all colorful and playful,
maybe because it's educational,
so it's probably students and
young people that like games.
So we decided to stay
with this game-y feeling,
game-y look.
And one thing I really liked,
and I think it was very
valuable from the beginning
with this project was
that we were developing it
very closely with our users.
So on the one hand,
because it's free to use for everyone,
so there were just a lot of people
sending us messages, emails,
we have a Discord channel,
so talking to us and
telling us their ideas
and what they would like to see there.
Also, what doesn't work,
if we had some bugs, that
was also very, very useful.
But we were also asking other researchers
and scientists, physicists to tell us
what they would like to see there,
what do they think would be great to have,
what features, what elements,
what kind of experiments
they would like to see.
And for example,
someone told us that it would be great
to see the Elitzur-Vaidman bomb test,
the thought experiment.
So we were like, okay, great, we'll,
we had a bomb already,
so we had to do some changes
to be able to add this,
to add this experiment,
but we did it.
And then my colleague actually talked with
Lev Vaidman and he showed
him the experiment.
And I don't think he was,
he had a lot of feedback.
He didn't immediately
understand everything
that was happening there,
so it was obviously very, very
important feedback for us.
And we tried to incorporate as much
of his feedback as possible,
but we also asked him
about some other things
he would like to see there
and what could be simulated there.
And for example, he mentioned,
"Oh, it would be great to have
indistinguishable particles
for two-photon interference
or the GHZ entangled state."
So we were like, "Okay,
great, let's do it."
And we added these and this
was from the beginning,
this was the process,
we were asking people,
and of course, you know, not,
we weren't incorporating
every single feedback,
but from the beginning this
process was very, very natural.
And we were just okay, trying to listen
and like, "Okay, let's do
it, this sounds great."
And you know, as I said,
of course the main usage was educational
and a lot of educators used
and still use this tool.
And we had a really nice situation
that I will talk about now
with a much older version.
It was few years ago, so
it was much, much older,
much simpler version of the lab.
It was just the beginning of the pandemic
and a professor from
Stanford reached out to us.
She found the tool online
and she reached out and she said
that she usually has those
hands-on, experimental classes,
but now the pandemic started
and everything moved online
and suddenly she was left with a textbook.
So she was looking for something
a bit more interactive,
a bit more fun for the student,
and she found our project.
And then of course she and the students,
they gave us a lot of feedback
and this was really great
and we made a lot of changes
according to their feedback.
And at the end she told us that,
"Even when it becomes possible to teach
my class in person again,
your website, your project
could help me scale
to a larger class size than is possible
when I require equipment for
hands-on demonstrations."
And I really, really liked what she said
because this is, in a way,
it really talks about what
I said in the beginning.
So of course this interface,
this is not instead of
the actual lab, right?
But it's a different
way to interact with it
and it's a different
way to learn about it.
So this professor, she would
still have this experimental,
this hands-on class,
but she could use this tool
to make a class to a much
larger group of students.
And for me, this is the
main reason to build
those visual interfaces,
not to exchange a
different type of interface
but to open this technology
to some new situations,
new use cases and new users.
And now I will show a third project,
a third quantum project.
And this is, it'll,
it's just a sneak peek.
I can't show the full project yet.
It's not released, we're
still working on it.
So I'll only show a bit of the design.
And this is something we
are working on with Classiq.
Classiq is an Israeli
startup based in Tel Aviv.
And we are working on this kind of
visual graphical interface,
graphical user interface
for the Classiq platform.
And just to give you a bit of context,
so this will be part of
a much broader product.
So it's not,
it's only a part of the,
of our Classiq product.
And the Classiq platform
allows user to design,
to build, to design a model
that can be later synthesized
into a quantum circuit
that is optimized in certain
way depending on the use case,
depending on the needs.
And later users can execute
the circuit on any of the
available quantum backends,
so quantum simulators and
actual quantum hardware
on in, all in one platform.
And the project I'm showing you will be
part of this first step,
so building the model,
building the functional
model, the algorithm.
And as I showed you this slide,
it's, we are building this
kind of node interface
and this again comes to this question
about how to make it as
intuitive as possible
and how can we learn from other solutions
from different industries,
different use cases,
but how can we learn from them,
from things that are
researched really well?
There are a lot of different products
and how can we learn from there
and build something for quantum?
And we decided to use this
kind of node interface
and on the one hand,
the things we researched and we looked at,
so one hand it will,
this whole world of electronic circuits,
schematics, netlists,
it's maybe not the most user friendly,
but there's a lot of
important solutions there
that are very, very relevant
for building quantum algorithms.
And of course, more
typical node interfaces,
for example, for 3D modeling like Blender,
there's some music software,
there's a lot of automation software.
So there are quite a lot
of different solutions
that were developed for
very different industries
and we're trying to learn from them
and see how can we translate it for,
into quantum.
And it's,
we try, I hope it will be very simple,
so the users will just choose blocks,
either functions or gates
or they can create their own blocks
and they just wire them together
and they can add more and
more blocks and wire them
and build the algorithm in
this very, very visual way.
They can merge them if you,
they have a lot of small blocks,
they can merge them into bigger blocks,
they can build their
own blocks from scratch.
And
I think it'll be also really good
for adding external data.
This is also something that comes back
when I'm talking with users
and especially users
from different domains.
So, someone from finance,
maybe they would just like to have this,
some kind of finance block
where they only upload
their CSV or some other
format of the data.
Also really great for all
sorts of visualizations.
That's very natural language here.
And of course we're still,
it's still not released,
so the use cases,
it's only something that
we think of
and I hope to learn
about different use cases
when we do release it.
But some of the situations where I think
it could be useful would
be like, for example,
for maybe domain experts,
like I said
about finance
and people that they might not,
maybe they don't want
to work in code so much.
It might be easier to,
for them to work with something visual.
But also I hope it will
be useful for researchers,
so I can imagine the situation
that someone is working on the research,
they're publishing the research
and then they can have this
interactive
visualization of their research
or interactive representation
of their research
that anyone can play
with, can interact with
and can maybe build upon
in a very intuitive way.
And of course for learning,
again all the visual solutions,
I think this is something
that is really a no-brainer for learning.
And I can imagine someone opening
an example of an algorithm
and then looking inside
and seeing what are the
different building blocks
of this algorithm
and trying to build their
own way, their own algorithm,
so I think this for sure will
be really valuable for them.
And again, this is just a sneak peek.
This is just a design.
So, but I hope that it'll be,
some first version will be available soon.
So stay, you, yeah,
you can check the platform
to see.
Hopefully soon it will be released.
And the last project I
wanted to show you is
something very, very different
and
it in a way comes back to this idea
of different users and different situation
and producing very different
or researching very different
types of interfaces,
of ways we can interact with technology.
And this is a project
I did a few years ago.
It was an art installation
for a theater play
about the human-technology interaction.
And it built this,
I designed this swarm of
electronic objects.
I designed objects and the electronic part
and those objects were placed
around the actors
and were also some kind
of an actor, in a way.
And the interaction was happening,
so the kind of the interface was,
it was a voice interface
so the actors would interact
with this installation,
with their voice
and the installation
would reply with voice
and with sound and with light
and would change depending on
how the actors interacted with it.
And this is, you know,
when think about this,
it's a very different use case
and a very different user type
than than physicist, for example.
But when we think actors on the stage,
of course having an
interface where they click
somewhere on the screen with a mouse,
that wouldn't be suitable.
That would probably be very boring
and just not something they needed.
And of course this is
in a way exaggerated,
but I wanted to show it that it,
we should really think about interfaces
as all the different ways we
can interact with technology
and that each different type of interface
refers to a different
or answers to the needs
of a different group of users
or a different situation,
a use case.
For example, physicist or actors.
Yeah, and these are the four projects
I wanted to show you today,
so thank you very much.
- Thank you so much for such a great talk.
Thank you for sharing
with us all your projects.
The first thing that when
we see all of these projects
and especially interface,
we see a lot of purple.
And I have a question about this
because also at YQI,
some of the work that we are doing,
like most of the quantum
is becoming purple.
Like, it's shifting towards this color.
I was wondering what's,
why did you pick this color?
Is it because it's more of a dark system
or like is it, did you
have a meaning behind it?
Like what's, why did you
pick this (indistinct)?
- Yeah, that, you know, the,
it's funny 'cause when I
put all of them together,
I also thought that
it's very, very purple.
It was something that,
it was very intentional
with Quantum Flytrap
and I really researched at the beginning
what are the colors that kind of.
(Klem Jankiewicz coughs)
Sorry, make people think
about quantum things.
And I was very happy
to find out that it was
all this like purple,
sometimes like yellow, pink.
But I think it's probably
a mix of, you know,
what works well
and what I personally like.
It's always somewhere in between.
So, and these are all like
dark background interfaces,
which I think this mainly
comes from the fact that
you know, with each project this would be
always a discussion
and we would think that
okay, with the users we have with mind,
usually people tend to
choose the dark mode
that's, but yeah, that's.
- Could be a debate in
the labs, the dark mode.
- Yeah, that there is a lot of definitely,
but that's why, you know,
it's like a first stage
and ideally there should be
the light mode added as well.
But also for sure something that's,
I do like strong color.
- Yeah, it's very.
- To be used.
- Very beautiful, yeah.
The reason why we are
using purple a lot is
because on the (indistinct),
you have like the one and zero
and then like it's a mix of
usually physicists use red and blue,
and so to sort of like hint
at the supervision of states,
it's nice to have this like
purple-ish thing that comes in.
So like it was interesting to see
even if it's not the main thing.
Another question that I have,
and for people in the audience,
if you are at YQI, feel
free to unmute the room
if you want to talk
or you can use the Q&A feature
at the bottom of the screen
to ask your questions.
One question I have is that
how did you jump from doing installation
and educational installation to quantum?
Like, quantum is seen as often scary.
Like, what was your process
and like how much did you know
before going into quantum
to working on this?
Because I think to create
very valuable interface,
you need to have a good understanding
of what's happening on the,
in the technology to be able to recreate
and simplify it without
oversimplifying it to,
for the audience.
- Yeah, so I started at CQT.
This was like literally the first time
I started to learn anything
about quantum technologies.
And you know, it started a year earlier.
I was participating in
this project made by,
run by MIT Media Lab in Berlin.
They had, did this like European
short, like one-week project
and invited all sorts of people
from Europe to participate
also about this crossroads
of technology and design,
music, art.
And I, you know, and
there was one person there
who was a quantum physicist,
and then somehow we stayed in touch
and a year later he was,
I saw that he's looking for people to come
with him to build a game
about quantum physics at CQT.
And I thought, "Oh that's perfect.
What could go wrong?"
So it literally started like this.
This wasn't intentional
and I thought it'll be,
you know, a fun, weird
project I'll have in my CV.
And I, and then, you know,
I started working on this
and I started working
with a lot of physicists and I thought,
"Wow,
this is the most interesting
and most amazing thing
you can imagine."
And I thought, "Okay,
that's what I want to do.
I want to stay in this industry."
But of course all of these
projects, you know, it's,
these aren't only my projects.
There was always a team of
developers and physicists.
So it's, I wouldn't be
able even to do the design.
It's a collaboration of the whole team
and it's everyone's ideas.
So there was, you know, a lot
of physicists involved here.
And with the time I of
course know more and more,
but I'm still not a physicist.
- No, but that's, I
think that's the beauty
of working at the interface
of science and technology
and art and humanities is that like
you really need to bring
people from multiple skills
because while a physicist
can be really good
at explaining the technology itself
or building the technology,
they might not be necessarily
good at doing interface
and like helping convey
ideas on the graphical level.
So like, I think that's
really a brilliant move
on all of this interface.
- Definitely.
- You also talked about the fact that
you are using a software technique
that people are used to,
for example, like the
same way that we have
still the little Save
icon being a floppy disk
in the corner of your screen
while we don't use floppy disk anymore,
it's interesting that you're going back to
how we make music,
how we make like Blender nodes and things.
Like, can you talk a little bit more about
why are we always looking,
like why are we always using for interface
stuff that reminds us of the past
for like the objects
outside of the visual?
Similar to how the notepad in on software
used to be a physical notepad
and they tend to be yellow,
the same way that the paper used to be.
Like that kind of thing,
what's the reason behind it
and how can you use that to your advantage
for the design of interface
for people who don't know
necessarily the technology?
- Yeah, so I think first of all
it doesn't need to be like this.
And I think there are many cases when the,
we want to, you know, when
you think about something
for example, very simple,
maybe some kind of a
website when, you know,
designers try to be sometimes, you know,
go crazy with the interface
and the whole idea is about
doing something very unusual,
very different.
So it really depends on the use case.
It doesn't need to be like this,
but in the case of quantum,
I think the technology
itself is so complex
that I always think
that I don't want to add
to this complexity by an interface
that is hard to understand.
And that's why
I try to design interfaces
that are intuitive,
that they're very, you know,
users immediately know what to do
or it's, you know, if
they need to learn a bit,
it's very little.
And to leave this time of learning
to learn about the technology
and not the interface itself.
And then of course, you know,
we all use interfaces all the time.
So this, by using the interfaces,
we'll learn about how this world works.
So then using certain solutions
from other industries,
from other totally different areas,
it's just something that,
it's something we know,
it's just something we've learned already.
So it's very intuitive
for the users to yeah,
to use the same,
to behave in the same way
when they see this interface,
even though it's quantum and not music,
but we see this channel
so it'll be very intuitive to know,
oh, okay, I can probably swap
or I can do this or that.
- And when you play
testing this application
or like educational content,
do you, I, because here
on the call right now
we have a lot of people who have
shared like mixed experience.
Some have not at all
understanding of quantum,
some have a little, some
work in quantum physics.
And so when you've tested
with all these people,
is there,
when you have somebody
who doesn't know anything
about quantum physics
playing on this platform,
how does it impact the fact,
like the interface and your work
then if you have that
person on the platform
and also a very qualified
person who knows a lot?
Like, how do you work to make sure
that the platform is available
for both type of users?
Because I think it's a bit of a challenge
to have something that is robust, complex,
but still making it available for people
who don't know anything.
Like, if they want to,
you've been writing 2023,
I think that was for your
New Year's Eve celebration.
I've seen online a couple
of like Christmas tree
and stuff like this, like
really fun interface,
but like, so to engage the audience
that doesn't know much about quantum.
Like, how do you convey these two type,
like how do you create interface
for these two type of users?
- Mm-hmm, so
I think there's this one idea
that I really like
that I think it was
Professor Mitch Resnick who built,
there's this software
for children to, Scratch,
to learn programming,
this like visual way of
how children can program
their own games or all sorts of things.
And he wrote a book
about building software
and there's this really nice idea there
that I think a lot about,
a lot when I'm designing the interfaces,
it's about making low floors,
high ceilings and wide walls.
So it should be very easy to start,
but at the same time it should give users
a lot of space to continue
beyond this like very basic examples,
very basic things to make,
sort of, for example, we have
the simulation in the lab, right?
So if I'm not a physicist,
I want to use it
because like I don't really understand it
or maybe I can use it and learn this way,
but it's there.
And for the more advanced users,
it gives them this
additional way to use it.
And also ideally to make those wide walls,
so to give possibility to different,
to, for users to go with this
into different directions,
to make their own things.
So it's not only to recreate what we did,
but you know, also to learn from them,
like we did in with Quantum Flytrap,
that it was like I said
about the development
that we would always listen to the users
and add new features or
new elements when they
were telling us that,
"Oh, I have this interesting
use case in mind."
So, but I also have a kid who's,
she's seven now and so I always show her
what I work on and she's also testing,
so the Pulser Studio was.
- So she's your play tester.
Oh, that's funny.
- Yeah, so like okay,
if she can arrange the atoms, that's good.
- That's a good thing, yeah.
Also, I like the fact that
you also work with theater.
I have a theater background,
so I used to be an
actor when I was younger
and switched to science later on.
Is there a way,
like I've always wanted to
bring theater into quantum.
I know it's gonna be very difficult,
but is there a way,
like, can you imagine a way of bringing
that type of arts into
the work of quantum?
Which could be,
like, I think really challenging
because we're talking about
very different things,
but like since you're mixing
technology and theater here,
like could we imagine a Pulser
integration, for example,
into a play or something like this?
What's your, what could be your,
like it's a tough, it's not
even a question but it's tough.
Like, that's really a domain
that I would be interested in going into.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
I would love to see something like this
or work on something like this.
I definitely really love the projects
that go out of this
realm of only, you know,
things that happen on the screen
or like at least this user
layer is on the screen.
So I definitely really like
all sorts of installations
and building and designing
those experiences in space.
Yeah, so I think there's definitely
a lot of space here for
some experimentation.
And it reminds me of
when I was in Singapore,
it was the beginning of my,
of me working with the quantum industry
and of course as I said,
I didn't really know anything
or too much about physics then.
Like probably, you know, school level
that I also forgot a bit by then.
And I remember that a colleague,
she's a quantum physicist.
She was explaining at certain point
it was something about light waves
and she was showing different
kind of waves with her,
like she did like this whole dance
and she was moving like she
was pretending to be the wave.
So probably there, you know,
there is a lot of space for.
- (indistinct).
- Thinking about something creative here.
- Fascinating.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talking to us about all these projects.
It has been really a treat.
For people, there was like
the URL on every project
so I will invite you to go online
and test all of this interface.
We'll keep an eye on the Classiq interface
to soon be able to play with it.
Thank you very much for your time
and we hope to see you at another
YQI non-technical block event soon.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you for inviting me.
- My pleasure.